the entire cast of Ghostbusters
afterlife is going to be returning to
Frozen Empire most notably the Spangler
family McKenna Grace as egon's
granddaughter Kena Grace is a
spectacular actress and she's basically
going to be our new CEO Finn wolfart as
his grandson and Carrie as his
daughter it's also been confirmed we're
going to be seeing Paul Rudd then we
have of course Paul Rudd a master
comedian probably Logan Kim Celeste
o'conor Bill Murray and Danny Potts
among many others who have had previous
roles in the franchise the only person
we're going to be missing from the
previous cast is Sigourney Weaver but we
are getting some fresh faces on the
screen like Patton Oswald James acter
and Emily Allen Lind